we understand that you want to qualify
Walter for the Oscars and there's a very
set process is that right what what is
that process and what are you doing so
we had a chance with Walter when we were
getting ready to release it we were like
little it take to qualify for an Academy
Award you know how do they decide who
wins an Academy there's got to be
something you go through so we just went
online and looked at their website and
they have a very extensive list of rules
for various types if you got a narrative
feature if you've got a in our case a
documentary feature the rules are
different from what you've need for
documentary short or a short narrative
or forward film and so we started to
read through them and I was as i was
reading them i'm like well it's not as
difficult as you might think i know that
they're making it you know be something
that they don't don't want just any film
like any you know low grade film that's
made kind of cast out too but they so
they do qualify some things that cost
some money and essentially these rules
sort of change from time to time but at
the current moment for a documentary
feature you have to screen commercially
for a week in new york and los angeles
and these are minimum requirements so
they're definitely looking for you to do
more as much as possible with film so
when you when we talk about New York
they're talking about Manhattan borough
so you got to be in the big city with
you know all the other films that come
out every week there's something like 20
plus films that are launched every
weekend in New York and you've got to
have reviews in New York and also
reviews on the west coast in proper
newspapers like the New York Times which
becomes fairly easy to do if you have a
commercial release in New York because
as of right now it's the New York Times
policy to review films their release for
a week there I have over the years
trying to get new york ties and various
like bigger periodicals to review my
films and they don't because of this
particular you know factor they have so
many films releasing there and then they
basically review
only what's really released commercially
so in addition to release commercially
on a documentary you have to send the
Academy 250 DVDs and that those go out
to their nomination committees who
decide who's who decided ultimately
what's going to be nominated and those
dvds cannot have any artwork on them as
we found the hard way we actually had a
DVD that was designed with a four-year
consideration cover on it and it's only
textured which we didn't consider art
but it was art ultimately it was not
just blank or you know not art and so
fortunately there they've been very
considering they're working with us you
know at each of the stages here and so
we have a quick solution of sending some
envelopes that they'll stuff for us it's
kind of interesting to see all of these
little pieces and parts you also have to
advertise in New York and la minute very
minimal requirements there but you do
have to have at least one ad in a couple
of newspapers before your premieres and
you have to have a certain amount of
screenings and they have to be between
certain period of time those are the
basic requirements to be able to qualify
a film for the for the Academy and of
course you send in some paperwork and
signed signed some stuff no money is
required in order to qualify other than
making your commitment to get your film
out commercially and that's definitely
like for most production companies is is
you know huge undertaking and cost quite
a bit I should say to that you have
cannot have screened your film anywhere
before it goes into a theater and has
its you know its release I believe it
can I believe it could have screamed at
like film festivals but it can't come
you know it has to have its its world
premiere can't be commercially available
you know as a as a digital download
as a DVD before you go into theaters and
have you looked at prior like I'm
thinking of innocent a i think was lets
out last year's or it was i just saw the
trailer and it looked amazing um but
have you looked at some of the other
success stories with that and tried to
kind of see what they've done or I don't
know I'm just wondering what kind of
background research do you do before you
make such a time commitment and money
I'm shirt you know i'm i'm kind of a
shoot from the hip guy a lot of times I
just get a hunch and I go with it and so
in this particular instance I didn't
really do a ton of research you know I
definitely saw their campaigns that read
about campaigns that felt like it wasn't
worth the costs to nominate or to allow
film to be to be considered for
nomination to qualify I i we actually
looked at it as it was part of our
Kickstarter campaign we wanted people to
be able to help us give us that
opportunity because besides the
opportunity to be qualified it was the
opportunity to play in New York I've
never played for a week in New York
never played for a week in LA you know
God opening in sort of a commercial
theater in this manner a lot of times my
films are going on theatrical tours
sometimes I'm with them we're playing in
all kinds of different places lots of
theaters I've definitely spent money in
in like outdoor towns at big theaters
like the boulder theater which is very
expensive to rip for one night you know
to launch a film but but I've never had
this sort of traditional film release
and I felt after ten years I felt
personally I deserved it and so I it was
one of those moments where I said I'm
going to do it and I want to get this
film out there it's a film that I don't
think has a lot of chances of getting a
nomination personally just based on what
I've seen out there that's been
nominated but I think it's a terribly
important film you know I I got a chance
to spend time with these people that are
in credit
well and I think if people see the film
for what it's supposed to be you know if
they really get it they'll see the way
that we have sort of captured their
lives and in kind of context to you know
Sarah in my life as we come together and
I think you know I think that there's so
many people that sort of miss the things
that matter in life and I try to like in
my films that try to put that out there
and so when I when I think about what we
tried to do and I don't know if we
achieved it yet because we haven't seen
how it plays out you know something that
personally I feel like why not my wife
Cathy why can't this potentially be
recognized by the Academy you know who
judge is what what in the cat you know
academy nominated film should be so we
figured we'd give it a shot and we can
never look back and say we did in and
now we know the process and it's not
that scary but it's expensive I mean I
guess you're going to sink if you go for
the very minimum which I think that they
prefer you to do more than a very
minimum and you're going to sink
probably twenty five thousand dollars at
least into it which is you know where we
hit with Kickstarter interestingly
enough but if you want to really support
your launch and you're going to open
commercially in New York and LA and and
potentially other theaters I mean you
really want to probably be thinking like
50 to 75 thousand dollars you know
depending on who you need to hire or how
much you can or can't handle publicist
for example they're not cheap and we try
to do a lot of our own publicity in
different ways but you know for this
release of Walter went ahead and hired a
publicist and I started calling around
and trying to get publicist to consider
the film and and it was difficult you
know there was a lot of that new
york-based publicist that you hear about
and you meet when you go to places like
conferences like South by Southwest and
they won't even consider you know your
your films because they've never heard
of you or you're too small or or whatnot
but but those that do like I mean
they'll they'll quote you like 4,000 or
five
for a release in New York and then you
know a few more thousand dollars for
release the release in LA you know I
mean you're looking at you know that
kind of money for a few weeks of
someone's time to ultimately go out and
push your film to the press and it
sounds like a lot of money but if you
don't work with those types of people
and you work with somebody who's a lot
lesser they don't necessarily have those
types of connections to where they can
make a phone call to somebody at the new
york times that they sort of know so
they know they can ultimately maybe get
you know some favorable press for your
film that being said you never know like
you can spend all that money and get
nothing we decided to go for someone who
was in the heart of the documentary
world at in New York she works very
closely with stranger than fiction doc
series by Tom powers and doc NYC Film
Festival and so she really had a lot of
connections and kind of helped helped us
build a grassroots game out there and
and he's just a really great personality
and really wonderful person and she's
worked very hard on the film and and but
I don't think she had has yet quite
those really big powerhouse connections
which in a way we kind of like because
that's where we're at and she just
matched who we were we mad she matched
the way we we feel about things and when
you can be okay with that be a piece of
that and not not worry too much that
you're not necessarily going to get that
you know the hundreds of huge articles
or whatever you know you kind of you
kind of let it be but it's it's always a
little tough because you're spending
quite a bit of money on PR and you don't
really know what it's going to do for
you